Thank you. Uh, my name is again, Josh,
his tail and I run accessible to
pan and it's a website day, dies,
shares the accessibility features of uh,
living in Japan with people who
are interested in visiting a,
they'd have a disability. I didn't
grow up in a height Roppongi hills,
but a instead of when I looked out my
window, this is what I saw. And um,
this is the view from my bedroom.
I live in a small,
small town outside of Oxbridge and it
was as her ex as I've Toronto called
experts. And, uh, it was me, my
sisters, my parents, and about 20 sheep.
Um, so that's why I like spending
most of my time looking at
now I have what's called cerebral palsy.
And a,
it's a very fancy way of saying
that I have brain damage. Uh,
there's two types of, uh, ways
to describe brain damage. And uh,
after your brain is filling this
developing and you may have an accident or
something like that,
then that'd be regular type of brain
damage through palsy happens when your
brain is still developing. So when you're
very young and because of that, uh,
as you develop, your body
will develop differently. Um,
and it can have a wide
variety. Um, for example,
some people can just have a little bit
of a trouble moving their arms around and
other people can be completely after
the stay in bed all the time. I'm,
I'm somewhat in the middle, I'm
classified as severe. Um, but for me,
the way it affects me is my arms and
my legs. So they're physically healthy,
but the signals from our brain don't
properly get conveyed to move the muscles
the way I want. And because it happened
when I was young, when I developed a,
for example, my hands, um, the muscles
of the bottom were always tight.
And so as I grew bigger, because it was
tight, my hands started to bend down.
So when you look at pictures, when I was
a kid, my hands were much more street.
And so that's where one of
the main differences between
regular brain damage and
cerebral palsy.
So would that mean for my daily life?
Well,
I have to have somebody who it's called
a helper and maybe an English would be
more commonly called a
personal care assistant.
So today I'm here with the highest son,
so I'm very thankful for his
assistance every day of my life. Um,
so what happens is I, uh,
people with disabilities,
you can get evaluated by the city
they're living in and they get a certain
number of hours that they can
use in their daily life. Um,
and then you get a contract with different
companies in your local area and make
schedules for your daily routine.
So my helpers help me from the
first thing in the morning.
So the first person I see in the morning,
last person I see at night is my
helper and a not so romantic, but um,
so, um, but uh, yeah, so
they helped me get up in the
morning and to have a shower,
get dressed, et cetera.
I get ready for work.
And then after work they help me maybe
with some shopping or with, um, uh,
cooking or cleaning around the house.
And then the nights they
helped me get into bed.
And do it all again the next
day for when I go out. Um,
my day life requires a lot of
planning. Uh, planning ahead. Um,
not something can just jump on a train
and go meet somebody somewhere. Um,
I need to think of, for example, if I have
that night, I have a helper scheduled,
I have to be back before the helper comes.
Uh,
we're also have to pay the cancellation
fee or it may not be able to get into
bed. Um, when I think
about transportation,
I always have to leave extra time and he,
uh,
transfer usually probably takes about
20 minutes longer than it says on the
Google maps. So, um,
I'd say those things into account when
I'm going out with friends as well.
I need to think about restaurants.
Um,
it can be a very big challenge
to find a place to eat.
It's a very simple task for most people,
but for me,
because of my electric wheelchair,
it's very difficult to get
into many restaurants, uh,
particularly in Japan where there tend
to be very small. Um, and there's a,
I love Japan, but I don't like,
again, con because it's a,
it's a step that you know, keeps me
out. So it can be discouraging at times.
I'm trying to go, maybe you want to eat
ramen and, um, so you're out with friends.
You want to go get Ramen, you find
a lot of delicious looking places,
but you can't get into any of them.
Uh,
and then you end up having to go to a
family restaurant or something like that.
And then,
so planning ahead is very important so
you can figure out what is available for
you.
So with all those extra requirements,
why would I come to Japan? Um, and
what was talked about earlier. Um,
I took a class in Japanese in high
school and my Japanese teacher,
he really loves Japan and that was
infectious. And so I thought, oh,
I wanted to try going.
And, uh, my parents,
they always encouraged
me to follow my dreams.
They always said that even
though you have a disability, um,
you can do what other people can do to
a certain degree or as the same as them.
Um, it may just take a bit more time
or do things a little bit differently,
but you should always follow your dreams.
Now they say they regret that because I
moved to Japan now and never go home. Um,
but, but when the first time I came there
was really little to no information on
accessibility in Japan. Um, now
Google was around at that point and,
but if there's nothing to find, then
your search results are zero. Um, so,
uh, through lot of phone calls
and very, very vague, um,
books and stuff or
decide to take the risk.
And I came to Japan with my dad for a
couple of weeks back in the year 2000.
And, um, I was really surprised
to find how to spell Japan was a,
it was different than my expectations,
I think. And, um, I realized that hey,
this is a place I could live.
And so after finishing university I
decided that I wanted to come and move to
Japan. When I did that, there was a
real requirement for a lot of logistics.
As I said,
I need helpers in Canada.
The government provides the
helpers in Japan as well.
The government provides a
helpers, but in the interim, um,
I need to bring somebody with me to take
care of me until I could get into the
system.
So I had to come with someone for about
six months until I was able to fully in.
And, um, as well as
finding a place to live,
it can be very difficult
to find an apartment.
It's accessible to wheelchair
users. Um, so yeah, again,
a lot of planning and to
overcoming logistics. Uh,
but I got here and I've been here
for 10 years now and as mentioned,
I became a Japanese
citizen last year and a,
so I'm actually no longer Canadian
citizen because I had to give up my
citizenship. But, um, but here I am to
stay for good. Whether you like it or not.
Uh,
the company I work at right now is called
as elite group and one of their court,
um, principals is giving back to the, uh,
going back to the society and your local
community. And uh, I feel the same way.
And,
um,
so I wanted to use the experiences I had
as a person with a disability does come
from another country and,
uh,
probably very few people
like that in Japan at the
moment. So I thought I should,
uh, use what I have to give back.
Um, so that brought me to the,
the need that a lot of people face.
I think that,
well it's true with those stairs here.
Um,
of course it started personal when I just
wanted to go out with friends or if I
wanted to go on vacation
in Japan, uh, just the,
the challenge of finding
the right information, uh,
because you don't want to go on a vacation
and then find out that you can't get
into your hotel because I'd
be very traumatic. Um, so
in doing a lot of research,
um,
I thought I was able to read Japanese now,
so I was looking at things in Japanese.
I realize there's still,
it wasn't much information in English,
uh, for people with disabilities. And, um,
just as an example here,
you're of course going to go to a tourist
sites when you're coming here. And, uh,
if you look at this website,
um,
you look at the information
that's available in English
and as very basic things
like the regular hours days close,
which is a very useful information for,
I'm just your average
visitor. Uh, but you know,
you don't know anything about it if you're
in a wheelchair, uh, what's available.
You know,
if you go all the way out there are going
to be able to actually enjoy the place.
But if you look on the Japanese site,
uh, they have a lot of information to,
for example,
it came,
how far can you go up the castle or their
wheelchairs available friends or their
wheelchair toilets available,
where are they? Um, so all
that information is there,
but it's available only in
Japanese. Um, so for most people,
they're not going to necessarily go
and look and translate the webpage,
a website, uh, because if you're not in
English, then there's nothing there. So,
so there's a real difference between the
English and Japanese versions of places
as well for your hotels, this website
and they have a, the universal twin,
um,
that sort of another side side notice
that the phrasing in Japan and in North
America or Europe or wherever it is
quite different. So Universal Twain,
if you said that at some data, I have
no idea what you're talking about. Um,
or a barrier freak NOI,
you would know what that means in,
in mostly English speaking countries.
Most people search for accessible.
So even if it was written
in as barrier free,
that's not likely going to click for
somebody who doesn't know the terminology.
And then again on the same site,
if you look at the English page of the
rooms didn't nonetheless the universal
twin being available. Now,
there's probably a practical
reason to this and that,
um,
they need,
they can't use the booking system to
book accessible rooms for the most part
because they want to ensure that,
uh,
it's people who are actually have
disabilities that are using it.
So generally you need to have some sort
of communication with the hotel to book
your room. Um, and so maybe the
hotel made a decision that, um,
we don't have enough English staff to
be able to handle those requests. Um,
or they might have come to the idea that,
oh no,
we are just going to be
coming visiting anyways.
So there's no point in
translating this webpage as well.
So as realizing that there's a lot of
challenges that people who want to come
just for vacation, um, have,
so that led me to the journey of a
starting to accessible to Penn. I,
I like this picture.
My mom took it.
I didn't know [inaudible] I wish she had
a better phone log. So better pictures.
So my mission statement for,
um,
accessible Japan is to provide as much
information as possible on accessibility
in Japan.
So travelers with disabilities can make
informed decisions based on their needs
so they can enjoy Japan to its fullest.
So the end result is I want people
to enjoy Japan. I love Japan.
That's why I've moved here and that's
where I want to stay here forever. Um,
and I want people to enjoy the,
his van as well,
but a lot of people dispersed when
they're looking for places to go.
If there's not the information there,
they don't want necessarily spend all
the money to come over here if they don't
know what they're going to come into.
Um,
so I tried to get as much
information as possible and uh,
there are so many different
types of disabilities.
I can't say displace successful.
This place is not acceptable because
that's not something I can decide for
everybody.
Um,
so what I do is I tried to provide as
much information as possible and then they
can make decisions based
on their own needs and uh,
whether they go to those
places are not so accessible.
Japan has been constantly pivoting
and updating, evolving. Um,
I like to take credit for
all of the ideas, but, um,
a lot of them come from interacting
with people who have contacted me. Um,
for example, I have a page on, um,
bringing your guide dog to Japan.
That's not something I've ever considered
a, but somebody asked me a question,
well, what's the system like
for bringing guy, Doctor Japan?
And because of that idea that that
were part of the webpage was born. Um,
so it's constantly been changing.
At first it was just basic
information on how to get around me,
be on a train or um,
what it's like to try to find a hotel or
just sort of very general ideas and as
well as a blog.
And they use the blog to introduce
different parts of Japan to people,
for example, um, how to find a
restaurant if you have a wheelchair or,
um, even parts of Japanese culture.
So there's the anime there,
a silent voice in the character
from that, uh, story. She has a,
she's deaf,
so she has trouble communicating.
And so that's sort of part of the story
and in general about human communication.
So somebody wrote a review for that
side, put that on there as well. So,
and then of course, I have a
youtube channel as well. Uh,
I use youtube different than a lot of
people use and that I look at people's
reviews of places and don't really listen
to what they're saying by constantly
looking at the ground, see if their
steps or if there's any barriers. Um,
so because of that I realized,
Oh, I thought I should,
I probably should have some videos as
well because it speaks much more than a
few pictures or my comments.
So I try to provide as much information,
the videos as well.
And again,
going back to the hotel,
so I created a searchable database
of hotels with accessible rooms.
If you go to places like rock
10 or other travel sites,
you have a little checkbox in the extra
information where you can check off is
accessible or not.
Uh,
but usually that just says that there is
an accessible room you still up to you
to go and research everything.
So I tried to correlate
all the information I could
get and put it into the
database.
So I got that either through the,
where the variation is available on the
websites or contacting the hotels with
surveys and asking. And as well as getting
people to put their own reviews on. Um,
and a lot of those things
include, uh, toilets.
This will come up a couple of times.
So I hope you use the toilets, um,
is something everybody needs to do.
And um,
it's something that's very important if
you're going to be spending the mind to
state place. And I'm in places
like Europe or in North America,
there are very strict rules about when
an accessible room is like they have, um,
maybe what angles, uh, the walls are
at, how you can approach the toilet,
how much space is between the beds, et
cetera. And it's all very well dictated.
So you can in general with insurance,
rent a room and a, you know,
you're going to be okay.
We're in Japan is,
tends to be more general
guidelines of what's accessible.
So you can find two places to hotels
with a quote unquote accessible rooms and
one will have maybe some handlebars
next to the toilet. And that's it.
That's the only difference from
a regular room. And other places,
we'll have these huge sprawling rooms
with the toilet that's covered in white
tiles and looks like a hospital with all
these equipment that you've never seen
before. Um, so it can be quite a variety.
So I tried to show that I'm on the reviews
of the hotels as well. Uh, bathrooms,
of course the showers are difficult at
times because people can necessarily get
into the bathtub.
A lot of the places in North America will
have a roll in shower so you can drive
your wheelchair right into
the shower area. Uh, but a
lot of places in Japan, very,
very few have those.
Um,
so I had a little life hack is that you
can, you can see on the ground there,
there's actually a drain on the floor. Um,
so as long as you don't tell the staff,
you can put the chair next to the bathroom
in the bathtub and shower there as
well as just information on
what the rooms look like. So,
not all of them have that
kind of integration, but as
much as I can get as well,
of course people want to see
things when they come to Japan.
So I write reviews of attractions.
Um, because I live in Tokyo,
most of the interactions tend to be in
Tokyo area by of some others as well.
So they have general information,
like a irregular Japan Guide,
whoever would have some
background information,
how to get there with the
hours are et Cetera, um,
by going to other details
as well. Uh, for example,
if they say they have an elevator,
um,
I tried to try it out and see what
it's like. So you're on the website,
it says there's an elevator,
but I wouldn't be able to use this one
by myself cause there's not enough room
to turn around or push the buttons.
But again,
it's just that doesn't mean
that you can't go there.
It's just you should know that in advance.
Uh, as well as maybe for the gardens,
the routes that are available
for accessible travel. Um,
some have like this is a Dq
van, I think. And it has, um,
equate sense of coverage of the grounds.
Uh,
but some places they only happened maybe
about a quarter of the places actually
accessible. So you, if
you're gonna be going there,
you might not to want to
intentionally go into that area
and just the little things that
may occur along your path, uh,
such as these steps.
And of course toilets if there's only one
more minute of quiet. So bear with me.
Um, so yeah, when you're going out,
you didn't say essential things
mean most people don't think about.
But if you're going to be traveling around
and you need to use the toilet in the
pinch, you want it to know
that something's available.
So this helps people go and just
sort of rest assured that, you know,
there is something there and I don't
need to worry about it too much. Uh,
the next thing is I did a,
um,
general glossary and a phrase
book for Japanese to English. Um,
and again, that was started because
someone asked me some questions,
how do you say this or this?
So I translated that,
that I'll wash it by page on that.
And actually lonely planet contacted
me and they're going to use this as the
basis for their, um,
accessible travel guides.
Okay.
And tourists. I, I'm not
a person who likes tour.
It's normally like to go on my own path
but never go. We're interested in tours.
And so I was able to work with a
couple of different companies to, uh,
consult on accessible tours in Japan.
This company is called the inside
Japan tours and they serve,
offer a complete package,
but there's a couple of other ones I would
work with that have a, does day tours.
And um, and so yeah, they,
it gives them a chance to experience what
it's like to go around and give it to
her. So we went to a couple of different,
uh, tourist locations in Tokyo.
We rode the train together because it's
one thing just to sort of read something
in the website. This is how it works
as opposed to actually experience it.
And within a couple of months
of actually having this tour,
they had their first disabled as guests.
And so they're able to give that
present to around Japan because of the
consulting.
And I'm,
I'm writing an accessible
Japan and we your number one,
but this is number two here on the screen.
A lot of people actually
request a wheelchairs or
other mental medical equipment
in it pinches, uh, for most people
they take their wheelchair with them.
But there's been times where
I've been contacted by somebody,
maybe they broke their leg two
weeks before their vacation.
I need to rent a
wheelchair, you know, or um,
I'm going with my grandmother
and she can't walk very far.
And do you know what plays,
I can rent the wheels wheelchair,
I don't want to buy one just for
coming in Japan. So, uh, I attend,
tend to work with a rental companies
for providing most of those.
I subcontracted them. Um,
but yeah, for in a pinch,
this one can fold it up and it's a bag
and I can send it by you been to anywhere
in the country within a day or so.
And then of course, people want to
take something with them sometimes, um,
to carry all the information. And it's
even if they have a phone with them,
they don't want to use the data or
something to search on the website.
So I made the accessible Japan
travel guide for Tokyo and uh, you,
it's available right now if you want to
buy it on that truths and look at that.
It's got five stars.
And recently I started the uh,
a forum for the website.
A lot of the interactions with guests
or with a different people have been,
um, very important questions that,
you know, if you're just doing email,
it's sort of one on one and only people
that are involved that email can see the
information.
But a lot of the questions I think could
be very helpful to other people as well.
Uh, so in a forum kind of base then
it's searchable. People can find it. Um,
when they're looking for things as well.
If there's something I want to put some
information on that doesn't necessarily
require a four page,
just having a little bit of a way to add
quick information has been a very big
help. And A, I've been growing steadily
compared to last year. I pretty much,
it's pretty much doubled in
access, um, just in the last year.
So that is very exciting,
except the more exciting thing is the
communication with people who are using
the website. And, uh, recently I
was contacted by someone who said,
your site has really encouraged
me to take my daughter to Japan.
She has cerebral palsy and
cannot walk very long distances,
so she needs a wheelchair
to usually get around.
We were planning a trip for next year.
And so when I talked with this person,
uh, his daughter loves anime,
so her dream is to go to Ikea,
Alberta and a knock on Broadway.
And so use asking about Nahko Broadway
and actually I'm not an enemy and so I'd
never heard of it. And so, but I took the
opportunity to add that to the website,
so I went and did a review of it.
Um,
but that was a real encouragement to me
that because that's the whole purpose of
this website is to encourage people
to come to Japan and enjoy it.
And to have someone actually say
that, you know, because of this,
I had the courage to bring
my daughter here. So,
okay,
so accessible. Japan and Google
have a very strong relationship.
I think the first thing is that our
shared goals and Google's of course,
is to organize the world's information
and make it universally accessible and
useful. And I think that's very
common goal that we have as well. Um,
I'm sort of maybe a microcosm
of that and that, uh,
I'm using a very niche information,
uh,
that not a lot of people use bites.
So put it in one place and make it
accessible and useful to people.
Let's see.
Uh, in my day to day use, of course,
Google search is probably the,
the biggest thing. I use a in a
two way kind of communications.
So people find, um, bunch of
bands or Google search, uh,
because of the nature of the website being
a preparation for traveling somewhere,
it tends that people only use it until
they go Japan and then after that they
don't really return. So the majority
of my visitors are new visitors.
So through Google search they're able to
find the website. And then for myself,
because I can't go to every place that,
um,
I need to go to or just to answer
random questions that come up, I'm,
I'm constantly googling
things. So I'm very, very, very
grateful for for your work.
And you can definitely put me at the top
of the rankings if you went intent. Um,
Google analytics and something
else I use quite frequently. Um,
and I'm actually slightly addicted
to it. Uh, have it on my phone.
I'm constantly checking how many visitors
I get to, how many visitors to get to.
Um, and it, but more importantly,
it helps me to focus, um,
through looking at the
statistics. I can see, okay,
well this area of the
website isn't very popular.
People aren't using it very much,
but this area is gay. A lot of hits.
So people have definitely interested
in this area. So I should put my,
because I have limited amount
of time and um, they need to,
I can focus on this so I can put my effort
into places where people can benefit
the most. Google maps of courses,
uh, essential for the, uh,
hotel searches as well as for me
for looking up information and uh,
routes for people. And of course,
uh, servers aren't free. So, um,
Google adsense helps offset some of
the costs for running the website.
So I'm very thankful for that.
And then sort of in closing and started
to have some general disability in
Google, um, working together
and the essentials of that.
So I think it's important to have a
wide variety of input on products.
Um, so it's either customers or people
who are working for the company,
they can input to those things and you
can find some unexpected things you've
heard probably many times about somebody
invented some product they thought was
going to go off and sell really well,
but it doesn't.
But then they had some
unexpected use cases for it.
And that ended up turning into be some
huge different world changing ivs.
So I encourage you to look for unexpected
use cases and a lot of people with
disabilities have them.
For example, a street view,
most people maybe would use it for
when they're driving to look for, okay,
I'll get you to turn here.
This is the landmark I'm looking
for or probably the most,
most people look at use Google and like,
hey look,
there's my house and get excited when
they see their car parked in front of
something or their dog
or something. Um, for me,
I use it all the time to do quick
accessibility spot checks. So I can,
if someone asked me a quick question,
I can go in,
look at it and street view and I
can give a rough idea of, you know,
what kind of barriers they might face.
If there's steps or something like that.
I use it on my own life as well.
And I'm looking for maybe like
a restaurant or something.
If there's no information
available on the website, I can uh,
go to the street view and I can
see, oh, oh, that's in the basement.
I can't get in there. Or, oh, it's on the
first floor, I can get it, no problem.
And not need to worry about anymore a
remote desktop. As I mentioned before,
I, um, I have my helpers help
me and when I get into bed,
I'm not necessarily ready to sleep yet
and I still have some things I wanted to
do, but because of the
schedules is from, um,
I can use Google chrome remote desktop
from my phone to keep working on my
computer. So that's a unexpected thing.
I think probably for most people.
And I think a big thing coming
up is Google home and, uh,
the smart speaker and a
Iot devices in general,
I think it's going to be a very big game
changer for people with disabilities.
Uh, most of the commercials
except or about, you know,
families getting up in the morning and
saying, you know, hey, turn on the TV.
And everybody that gets excited about
that. But I think more important is that,
you know,
somebody who can't move and can't use
their arms and legs very well can use that
and they can live a more
fulfilling life without, uh,
as much need for other
people to help them out. Um,
I've dropped the remote control on my
TV at times when there's been no help
around it. I can't pick it up.
And, uh, thanks to my Chromecast,
I can watch something else on TV
without having to worry about that.
So look for those unexpected use cases.
And since I have your undivided attention,
um, everybody, a dream list with me for,
um,
for some Google products and mostly maps,
I think because it has the biggest
impact for a lot of people's lives or at
least for mine anyways,
uh, accessible exits. Uh,
right now I think I'm uh,
maps,
it will show you where the exits
are for train stations and subways,
but not necessarily which one
has the elevator edit. Um,
and I spent numerous,
um,
I mean it's of my day trying
to find which place has a,
an actual exit and that
doesn't come up sometimes.
And if it had that could really make
things a lot easier and smooth for
transfers or just going out and about,
um,
as well as a toilet. So this
is the last time I promise. Um,
there was an app that I used
to use called a check a toilet.
It's a Japanese sort of
crowdsourced a application.
And so people would use
the maps API and they'd,
they'd put pens down for where
they're accessible toilets and um,
they could share pictures and um,
information on them.
But because nobody's really
been updating it, it's sort of,
it's been depreciated so you
can't actually use it anymore. Um,
so it can be included into Google maps
somehow there where the nearest toilet,
sorry.
Cause that it could help a lot of people.
I think there's lost Twitter
thing, I promise. Um,
and accessible route option as well. Uh,
right now you can choose things like, um,
minimize transfers or minimize walking
distance if there is an option for
accessible route a number of times.
If he choose the walking path
and you come to a busy street,
it'll go over the bridge
to cross the street.
And that's the path that
you're usually shown,
but of course that doesn't work for me.
So sometimes they're following the map,
but all of a sudden, oh, there's a bunch
of steps I can't get over the other side.
So having some sort of accessible
route would be fantastic.
Accessible hotel rooms, whether
they have them or not. Um,
when you lit search and maps,
you know,
you choose a hotel and on the left hand
side it will show you a, for example,
what the price ranges or the website,
the phone number, et cetera. And, uh,
lately I thank you very much for adding
accessible stations on for the train
stations knows that if you have the
same thing for accessible hotels.
So I've had just an extra line that said,
accessible room available. Yes or no.
That could definitely help a lot of
people searching for hotels and indoor
mapping of course.
And I'm sure it's something Google's
working on and could help for finding your
way around finding elevators
instead the stairs.
Cause a lot of times elevators are
buried way deep into different areas
and maybe possibly a bug bounties
for, uh, accessibility. Um,
if,
I'm not sure if you know,
but in Japan there are a lot
of places called workshops.
So for people with different
disabilities that can't get regular jobs,
maybe they work in these special workshops
where they'll maybe sort of bottle
caps or they'll put
chopsticks into the holders,
etc. And it sort of a way to have people
with intellectual disabilities have a
job. If they could maybe maybe
work team up with Google,
it can be a good CSR opportunity to
maybe go and check the information that's
been added to the local guides,
but whether it places accessible or not,
and it's finally, it's rumored that
accessibility benefits many, uh,
everybody maybe thinks that, oh, well it's
for a certain group of people, but, uh,
you know,
if we all live along and if everybody's
going to become disabled in some way,
whether it's your eyesight gets bore or
your knees go out and you can't walk as
far. And, um, I think
it's to be thought of,
not as special money used on this
group, but as opposed to, um,
investment in your future. And that's why
accessibility is very important. Today.
I was on the way and I transferred at
Morty Sta and in front of me in the
elevator,
there's an elderly couple and there's a
couple of mothers with baby strollers,
and there's people with injuries.
And those people are all using things
that were quote unquote designed for
people with disabilities.
So it's important to remember that
accessibility is for everyone.
It's also for the person
delivering Pacu Been, uh,
they also appreciate the
slopes and the elevators.
And then finally,
a real dream request is,
I know that you guys are trying to
get as much information on mapping,
so if you need another Google car,
let me know.
You can stop it on the back part and I
will gladly Gore ever. You want me to?
All right.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible].